first and foremost congratulations um on
the children all your babies and all
that how's it going
you know what it's so funny the plural
children was something i never expected
i had
i would be saying especially to a mom of
three i'm like holy cow i went from like
being like in my 20s saying
ah i'm good i don't really want to have
kids so like
i had a whole household full of kids now
i got two boys and a girl
it's awesome it's honestly the unknown
is is probably one of the best things in
life actually living out and seeing
where i am now is pretty pretty cool
so yeah mom life is good and i'm a
working mom so it
makes me even happier it's a great
balance yeah i couldn't agree with you
more i have
just one six-year-old but it was the
same thing in my 20s i was like ah kids
scary and now
it's scary right my life is so full and
amazing
and wonderful what about the youngest
one kenna is the sweetest little baby he
like adores his big brother
isaiah is only a year and a half as of
yesterday and he like just
watches him and he smiled i already know
kennan's gonna get the blame for all the
bad stuff that isaiah's gonna do
because he's just so cute he's gonna
follow whatever his brother tells him to
do so i can already tell
the admiration is there but he's the
sweetest he's just a really happy baby
he's so
chubby he's really chunky baby
um by far out of all of my babies the
chunkiest and i love it
i love it it's so cute so many rolls
it's delicious
we're gonna be here for a few days we
can avoid each other easy
yeah mm-hmm don't expect me to sing your
wedding good i don't tell them you're
sick or something call in
i will gladly do that well good all
right let's talk about this movie a
little bit
i saw it i thought it was a delight what
can the fans expect from this movie
my character erica is you know she's a
passionate dreamer
she's put her whole life into her music
career and unfortunately
her music career gets shattered by
her record label and it's not gonna
happen she's lost everything
she doesn't know what she's gonna do
next until her best friend offers her
the position to go to this beautiful
island in mauritius but she gotta be a
resort singer not ideally what she
wanted to
to be or to do but you know what are the
odds she's gonna bump into anybody
especially her ex-fiance
oh yeah it happens this movie is about
kind of like beating the odds kind of
going through
major heartbreak for you know so many
things that you have for love and for
music
um that erica has and then confronting
life
head on in the most beautiful place
mauritius so it's a really sweet movie
it's got a lot of heart to it it's a lot
of comedy and it's really fun
and funny so i'm happy i got to play out
this role and i get to sing in the movie
too
speaking of singing alicia keys is a
producer on the project how's it been
interacting with her on this and do we
put her in the sequel or what i could
see y'all
two playing next to each other i mean
can we bring her in to leave
i need to get married in the secret to
somebody no i get to sing her song which
is cool she had a big part to do
especially with the music
on this project and i got to sing her
song no one a couple different times in
the movie it's a
kind of like plays out throughout the
whole movie and it's like the couple's
song between her and her ex-fiance and
then now the new song that her beyonce
and her
his new fiance wants to you know at the
wedding it's all confusing
but at the end of the day i got to be
able to sing her song and she
said yes she approved it and i love it
and um i'm happy that i was able to play
erica
singing no one because you know the
music
song is a song that everybody loves and
it also plays a good role in telling the
scene
caleb makes more sense hi erica nice to
meet you what was it like filming on the
beach you brought the family down was it
a big family vacation or was it right
there yeah i did it was a family vacay
it's my first time i really kind of had
like my little entourage
i usually go and film things by myself
but this time i had my husband i had the
bait i had isaiah
i was pregnant i had my mom i had my
sister and my nephew
so it was awesome we like quarantined
together
we like tried not to over eat all the
delicious food we worked out like crazy
we went to the beach
went fishing went to the winery like
anything you can think of you do on
vacation we did it and
we did it good it was really good
honestly filming this movie was like
work and play and a lot more play oh my
goodness
what was it like filming during
pregnancy was it challenging for you or
were you just feeling great the whole
time
i was feeling good it wasn't challenging
i think the challenging part was
i didn't tell anybody on the set
my stomach started to grow and it
started to grow so it went from like
a flat stomach when i got there and then
within two months you know you start to
like grow
so literally the last week i told
everyone they were like
um we knew that is so fun
so i didn't want it to get in the way or
anybody to feel like they had to give me
special treatment i was like no
please don't say anything hey so what
are you doing here so far away from
where you normally are i'm here singing
um i think what brings you here
is way more interesting
uh well erica this is beverly jason's
fiance
erica nice to meet you talk to me a
little bit about the themes of this
movie right it's so it deals in
heartbreak and getting past that
what's your go-to when you deal with
those crying or hard moments in life
are you like ice cream on the couch by
yourself or you onwards and upwards
girls night out
oh girl oh all the way you beat me to it
it's more about like
girls vacation like where are we going
we're leaving town we're gonna forget it
all
we're gonna have a good time and maybe
when i get back i'll remember it again
but in the meantime i need my girls to
just show me a good time so it's usually
that it's my girls like
they're my go-to or my sisters or
something but a good vacation is
definitely it for me
onwards and upwards all right listen you
play an aspiring
singer in this movie once upon a time
you were an aspiring singer
when did you know that it was happening
for you oh
you know i think i knew that it was
happening
when people actually started to say my
name the right way
when they said christina milian instead
of milan
and yelano or milienna
i had my name pronounced so many
different ways so when i
finally heard people start to say my
name the right way and they
and just even say my name or asking for
an autograph
like that in itself was like wow this is
really happening this
is cool my first autograph was really
like an awakening for me like this
is me this is really happening i
practiced my signature
and that autographed many times and i
finally got to put it to use
you